what up space fam golden here from anime
outpour back at it again to discuss
all 20 titan shifters and their powers
explained about three years ago i went
through
all nine types of ld and their powers
but it's about time for an updated
version that takes into account all the
new things we've learned since then
and all of the new titan shifters that
have been introduced
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button to
let me know
really destroy it if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos
if you haven't subscribed yet make this
the day you subscribe
and while you wait for the next new
video to drop feel free to check out our
growing attack on titan playlist where
we got videos about all of the ackermans
and their powers
the titans ranked from weakest to
strongest and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and
all as you may well know by now emir
fritz was the founding titan and will
address her specifically later on in
this video but for now all you have to
know
is that she possessed all of the titan
powers emir died 13 years after
inheriting her titan powers and
eventually they were split into 9
different titan powers
these included the founding titan the
colossal titan the armored titan the
attack titan the female titan the jaw
titan
the beast titan the car titan and the
warhammer titan
the last titan to be revealed in the
story now let's jump into each titan
power and their known shifters
it makes sense to start with amir fritz
the founding titan the girl who started
it all
for a long time people viewed her as
either being a devil
which was the view from the marlene
perspective or as being a goddess which
was the view from the aldean
restorationist's perspective as aaron
krueger would go on to mention neither
of these extremes
seemed very believable and he was right
as aaron would later tell
amir fritz she's no god just a person
and emir was just a person
she was a slave of the aldean king long
ago about 2000 years ago
she wasn't born with titan powers but
got them one strange day
when she was running for her life
because she let a pig get away while
people were hunting her down and she
even had multiple arrows inside of her
she stumbled upon a massive strange
looking tree
she entered it and fell down into the
water below it was at this
point that a spine-shaped creature
attached itself to amir's own spine
and this explains why as rodrice
explains
the power of the titans is inherited by
biting through a human spine
and ingesting their spinal fluid after
the spine-shaped creature
attached and combined with the mirror
that was when she transformed into the
first ever titan
as a titan shifter the king could see
her potential and decided to keep her
and use her newfound power for himself
even though emir could absolutely
destroy the king if she wanted to
she had internalized a slave mentality
and obeyed the royal family's wishes
she used the power of the titans to
build roads cultivate the wastelands
make bridges between the mountains and
defeat enemy nations like the people of
marley
within the span of 13 years after
inheriting the power of the titans she
went on to give
birth to three daughters fathered by the
king of eldea she died when she took a
flying spear in place of the king and
while everyone expected her to get up
and heal as usual
she didn't her daughters maria rose and
sheena ate her body so that the king of
aldia could continue to use the power of
the titans
on his deathbed the king told his
daughters to give birth and multiply so
the blood of emir never dies out
thus the subjects of emir which includes
most of our main characters
are called that because they possess her
blood which had been passed on
through the generations only those with
her blood can become
titans because emir died after 13 years
of inheriting the power of the titans
and she was the strongest ever titan
shifter
it is said that no other titan shifter
can ever hope to live beyond the 13 year
mark
this is known as amir's curse however
emir didn't just die
she went on to a mysterious unknown land
where the paths that connect
all subjects of emir are visible from
this unknown land that subjects of emir
can sometimes enter or catch glimpses of
emir continues to slave away she molded
the special earth there
into titans and that's actually how
titan transformations and regeneration
come about in the real world
it is noteworthy that this dimension
transcends time and works in a way
completely different to how time works
in the real world the founding titan is
known
as the coordinate because that is where
all the paths which are connected to all
subjects of emir
converge royal-blooded eldians who had
the founding titan power could gain
access to this unknown land of paths
and give orders to amir and thus long
after death
emir would continue to work away
tirelessly as a slave of the royal
family
obviously since all the nine titans come
from amir and are simply fragments of
her power
it is logical that she could use every
single titan power that we're going to
discuss
in this video but the founding titan
specifically can communicate with all
subjects of emir no matter the distance
change the body compositions of subjects
of emir alter their memories create
countless colossal titans use them to
create giant walls and then release
those titans on the world and don't fall
for the idea that all the titans are
created equal
because the founding titan is by far the
most op since it lets you straight up
control the other eight titans if you
wish to most recently
emir was able to summon past users of
the nine titans and launch them at
reiner mikasa levi and the rest
they had no choice but to retreat when
they got the chance
as we know this titan power was passed
on through the royal family
eventually came to carl fritz the 145th
king of eldea
and the first king of the walls the dude
was sick of the horrors fighting and
destruction that he witnessed and
decided to let the aldean empire
collapse
he peaced out to the island where our
main story begins with some of his
people he built the walls using colossal
titans and rewrote everyone's memories
inside the walls
so that they thought they were the last
remnants of humanity notably certain
groups like the ackermans were not
affected by this memory manipulation
while most founding titan users inherit
the lost memories of mankind
king fritz also made sure that future
royal-blooded users would inherit his
pacifist ideology
this meant that like karl they would not
use their powers to fight back against
the titans or against the rest of the
world when they finally came to wipe out
the island the royal family secretly
changed their name
from fritz to reese and the valentine
power continued to be passed down
eventually it was inherited by rodris
and yuri reese's father
although the royal blooded inheritors
after carl possessed the same power in
theory
they were much weaker in practice
because carl's will
kept them from fully using the power so
when his sons begged him to free
humanity within the walls from the
titans father rhys refused and never
revealed why
eventually the falling titan was passed
on to yuri reese who as mentioned wanted
to free humanity within the walls from
the titans before he inherited the power
however he inherited carl's philosophy
and changed his mind
about destroying the titans just like
his father before him
yuri also became kenny ackerman's best
friend after he made the latter
feel completely powerless by using a
partial titan transformation
in order to grab hold of him and trap
him kenny and rod viewed yuri
as a god because of his vast knowledge
and immense power
eventually yuri passed on the power to
frieda rhys his niece
and rodrice's daughter frida would visit
her half-sister historia and then
proceed to erase her memories after
their meetings using the founding titan
power
she was inexperienced though and so
actually managed to lose in a titan
battle against grisha's attack titan
pretty shocking outcome
considering the potential of the
founding titan grisha because he was not
royal blooded could not use the founding
titan power but at the same time
at least he wasn't affected by king
carl's ideology
he let himself be eaten by his son aaron
and thus aaron inherited the founding
titan and the attack titan from his
father of course
he too wasn't royal blooded so the
founding titan power remained largely
dormant inside of him there were
exceptions like when he made contact
with dina fritz's royal blooded titan
and then managed to command the
surrounding mindless titans
the key to using the founding titan
while avoiding the restrictions of the
king's ideology
seemed to involve a non-royal-blooded
user coming into contact with a
royal-blooded titan
eventually aaron made contact with zeke
his half-brother
and dina fritz's royal-blooded son and
gained control
over his founding titan powers after
convincing emir fritz in the unknown
lands that she didn't have to be a slave
to the royal family anymore from that
point on aarons had practically
limitless power not only could he
control the other titan shifters like
armin and reiner
if he really wanted to he can even
through emir fritz
summon titan shifters of the past and
use their powers
as if unleashing countless colossal
times to fly in the entire world
wasn't op enough aaron unleashes
bertolt's colossal titan
past warhammer titans a beast titan that
looks like a reindeer
an armored titan that looks like the
thing from the fantastic four and many
more
they come out of his giant skeletal
frame that towers over colossal titans
in size
and at this point mikasa levi reiner and
everybody present
knows that they have to retreat using
falco's flying titan
because this kind of battle is
unwinnable i think people reasonably
assumed
that aaron would have to absorb the
other titans to use their powers
but the last chapter has clearly shown
that not all titan powers are created
equal
and defending titan if it wishes can do
just about anything
next let's move on to the colossal titan
power before aaron fully unlocked the
founding titan power and entered his
giant godzilla skeletal form the
colossal titans seemed to be the biggest
of the nine powers
compared to friederich's founding titan
which was about 13 meters tall
the colossal titan is 60 meters tall and
there's a reason the colossal titan was
called the god of destruction by marlei
because compared to most of the others
the destruction it can cause is for lack
of a better term
colossal albeit nowhere near as colossal
as the amount of destruction that aaron
can cause
and has caused recently the colossal
titan has three main distinguishing
features when compared to the others its
size
its ability to produce a strong and hot
steam that can prevent others from
coming too close to its body and most
notably its ability to create massive
explosions
its massive size may mean it's slower
than most
and the user can transform less often
and for shorter periods of time but it's
also
stronger allowing the user to destroy
the gates of the walls with just one
simple kick the steam it can give off
burnt arm into a crisp
and if bertolt didn't stop using this
ability aaron wouldn't have had the
chance to get close to his nape
however the drawback is that the more
you use this ability
the thinner the titan's body gets
because it is burning through itself
ultimately if used too much this ability
will completely burn through the titan
body leaving the user vulnerable
and then there's the explosive
transformation which is the only
possible power
that armin and the rest thought could
maybe let them compete with or beat
aaron
however armin is caught before he could
transform and thus we don't know if it
would actually significantly
slow down godzilla aaron or not still
though the fact that they put so much
faith
into this ability shows how much
everyone respects its devastating power
if the user wishes to his titan
transformation is accompanied by a
nuclear nuclear-like explosion that
destroys anything in its path while
creating a giant mushroom cloud
armin used this ability to devastate
marlei's navy fleet
not a bad opening act if you're watching
this you know that bertolt was the first
known user of the colossal
titan and then the ability was passed on
to armin armin was on his deathbed
and the only possible way to save his
life was to turn him into a titan
shifter
because of their regeneration powers the
fact that he also got
all the other colossal titan powers was
a bonus although berto's colossal titan
and armin's colossal titan have
distinguishing physical features when
compared to each other
especially around the face area it
appears that they have
all of the same powers we don't know yet
if armin possesses any abilities that
berto didn't but we also haven't seen
a lot of armin's colossal titan in
action so it's possible if unlikely
that he has some unique ace up his
sleeve notably armin did inherit
bertolt's memories and sees visions of
him from time to time
it definitely seems like he inherited
bertolt's crush on annie
or at least bertolt's presence in his
body seemed to amplify armin's own
feelings towards annie but enough about
titan love
let's move on to the armored titan the
armor titan has become a bit of a joke
at this point and i'll explain why it is
about the size of most
mid-range titan shifters at 15 meters
tall
its distinguishing feature is its armor
while most titan shifters
can use hardening in one way or another
the hardening doesn't usually cover
their entire bodies as it does with the
armored titan
it seemed cool at the beginning in
theory its full body armor would serve
to strengthen its defense
and offense cannons and other titan
punches wouldn't do much damage
while a charging armored titan possessed
enough strength to break through the
gates of the walls
the drawback is that the armor makes the
armor tighten slower
armor can be shed to increase speed but
it comes at the price of lowering
defense
the armored titan was respected as
marley's shield a symbol of its
indestructible power
however the problem was reiner kept
losing and the shield kept getting
destroyed we see that z can easily
destroy
reiner's armor off screen aaron destroys
it through wrestling and then through
hardened titan fists
then a nation devises anti-titan
artillery that can destroy it too so
it's come to the point where the armor
kind of just seems to slow rhino down
without giving the benefit of
indestructibility that it was initially
supposed to give
notably the armor can protect against
the colossal titan's explosion ability
which is cool but that just makes me
think that the founding titan would be
okay against the explosion ability too
and speaking of the founding titan it
can also strip the armored titan of its
armor
whenever it wants to as well i know
there are big armored titan fans out
there and believe me i'm honestly not
trying to hate on the armored titan
power
but it truly seems like it's become less
and less useful as the story's gone on
next let's look at the attack titan the
attack titan is perhaps more hype than
any other titan simply because it lends
its name to the title of the series
in japanese the attack titan and the
title of attack on titan are spelled the
same way
so clearly this power is especially
significant the attack titan is another
50 meter tall titan
the first known inheritor of the attack
titan aaron krueger aka the owl
said and i quote in every era the attack
titan has always moved ahead seeking
freedom it has fought on for
freedom end quote as far as the attack
titan's distinguishing abilities go
i'd break them down into three main
manga strengths that make it pretty
special
and one anime only ability one of the
attack titan's distinguishing abilities
is its incredible strength compared to
his body size this
increased strength makes it ideal for
attacking after he drank the bottle
labelled armor aaron's attack titan
could harden its fists
and use them to break through the armor
titan's armor pretty much making the
armor useless aaron's attack titan could
also lift a giant boulder
even giant for a titan and carry it all
the way to the wall to plug a hole
while aaron krueger in turn lifted and
destroyed a giant marleian ship in his
titan form
another notable attack titan feature
appears to be endurance
which again goes with the idea of
attacking and always moving forward that
is associated with this titan
in marlei aaron transforms into a titan
three times
and is fighting and exerting himself all
the while porko is shocked when he sees
the third transformation
despite transforming into a titan first
he's also the last titan standing the
two features i just mentioned are
notable compared to some of the
other titans but there are titans like
the colossal titan who are stronger and
titans like the card titan who have
better endurance this final power that
i'm about to mention
as far as we know is completely unique
to the attack titan
of course i'm speaking about the attack
titan user's
ability to see the memories of future
users this
is why aaron krueger mentions mikasa and
armin before they're even born grisha
explains this insane ability when
talking to rory's family before taking
the founding titan
power first he says and i quote from
long ago the inheritor of the attack
titan never obeyed others
it's been all to resist the
self-righteousness of the king
end quote then he goes on to say that
the attack titan is capable of knowing
the future
through its future inheritors it was
actually through this ability that aaron
sent specific memories to grisha
in order to push him to take the
founding titan so aaron could inherit it
and as i explained in my aaron's final
titan explained video
past aaron could even see future aaron's
memories when past
aaron inherited grisha's memories of
future aaron's memories
you can go back and replay that sentence
if you need to but the main takeaway
is that the attack titan as zeke says
has the power to transcend time
and affect the past by showing memories
to past users
that serve the future user best then
finally there's the anime only berserk
or rage mode
or whatever else you want to call it in
the anime aaron's titan's eyes start to
glow blue
his titan body is surrounded by flames
and lava-like veins and he
seems to gain power and speed which
allow him to defeat
the female titan that was beating him
before the berserk transformation
this could just be an anime only form
which will never come up again but it
does seem to go along with the idea of
the attack titan and always moving
forward because when
aaron seemingly lost consciousness his
titan body kept attacking and moving
forward on its own
we'll see as the story wraps up if this
form ever shows itself again
but for now it just seems like an anime
only change
done to make this specific battle more
hype and intense for the season finale
there were three known users of the
attack titan first there was aaron
krueger he worked for marley
and pretended to be loyal to them but
was actually an aldian spy known as the
owl who eventually passed on his power
to grisha
when his 13 years were almost up kruger
as mentioned transformed into the attack
titan and used it to lift and destroy
a giant merlion ship he killed the
merlin soldiers present before passing
on the power
grisha took the power and used it to
make it to the outer wall alive
he eventually met carla and had a son he
seemingly named his son aaron in honor
of aaron krueger
grisha's version of the attack titan
notably had a beard
and was strong enough to take out frieda
reese's founding titan which is supposed
to be the strongest of the nine titan
powers however frida was inexperienced
and as grisha mentioned her powers were
limited because of carl fritz's ideology
finally after gaining the founding titan
power grisha turned his son into a titan
and let himself be devoured
thus our protagonist aaron yeager became
the holder of both the attack
and founding titan next let's turn to
the female titan
and there's only one known user of this
titan power so far and that of course
is annie leonhardt or marley explains to
us that the female titan is an
all-purpose unit capable in every area
in addition to high mobility and
endurance the titan's hardening
abilities combined with annie's martial
arts abilities make for an incredibly
destructive force
the female titan is also able to summon
pure titans though her range is limited
and by summon they simply mean
that with a scream the female titan can
attract surrounding mindless titans to
her
we also later figure out that the female
titan can take in parts of other titans
and manifest those titan's abilities
herself
a pretty insane ability reminiscent of
tamaki's manifest quirk from my hero
academia
because of this ability according to
annie the military made her choke down
all kinds of things we also know that
annie was the first to form a nearly
indestructible crystal around her actual
body
now as we'll see when we get to the
warhammer titan the tiber's sister was
able to form a similar crystal around
herself
is it something all titan shifters can
learn to do did annie eat a part of the
warhammer titan at some point and learn
to do it from that
and is it a coincidence that the only
two users who have used it were female
titan shifters
all of these questions remain however we
do know that this crystal is so strong
that the only known way to break through
it up to this point
is by using the jaw titan's insanely
powerful claws or jaws
and that about covers it for the female
titan she had great endurance
and went on the island could run all the
way to the outer wall
while carrying reiner and bertolt it
exhausted her but the fact that she was
able to do it by herself when originally
she was supposed to switch every so
often with marcel's jaw titan
shows how impressive her endurance can
be when it has to be and annie's version
is most likely more powerful than past
users because of her impressive martial
arts skills that she can really make use
of with her titan
form and hardening abilities and a lot
of people wonder about this but
unfortunately we still don't know what
would happen
if a male user tried to inherit the
female titan power
next we have the kartine aka the
quadrupedal titan meaning it travels
around on all fours
it is only 4 meters in height and its
only known user is the warrior peak
finger when compared to the other titan
powers the kart titan stands out for its
unusually high endurance that makes it
well suited for long missions
she can maintain her titan form for at
least two months straight
since the user doesn't need to regularly
change back into their human form
it's possible for armaments and or cargo
to be equipped to the cart titan
you could attach armor or carry a firing
squad on you
or even an anti-titan artillery cannon
for these reasons it's one of the most
versatile titan powers the kart titan is
also known for its speed
like the jaw titan its speed allowed
peak to save zeke from levi
and reiner from hanji the fact that it
was fast enough to catch both of these
seasoned soldiers
off guard and then get away is
remarkable we have also seen pique
release
focused steam in her titan form which
saved her from jean's thunder
spear notably peak's version of the card
titan is one of the few titans that is
capable of speech
this may or may not have to do with her
intelligence which she is well known for
pique was actually chosen for the card
titan because of her strong judgment
however there are significant drawbacks
to this titan power
it doesn't have a strong defense as
gabby points out
the kart titan isn't as tough as some of
the others and the user's body takes
longer to repair from damage
furthermore because the titan form tends
to be used for such long periods of time
pique loses the ability to walk on two
feet she's seen crawling on the floor
after she gets back from her mission on
paradise island
and as she's adjusting to walking on two
feet again
she needs the support of crutches last
we saw pique was possibly mortally
wounded
on the back of aaron's giant skeletal
titan aaron manifested the tiber sister
version of the warhammer titan and had
it stabbed the card titan with a trident
pique did not get off the giant titan
with reiner mikas and the others
so if she doesn't die it is possible
that she'll get absorbed by aaron like
zeke was
this absorption may not be permanent but
it is possible that the next time the
survey core and warriors fight aaron
he'll be able to use armin's colossal
titan and
peak's car titan against them just as he
used zeke's beast titan before
and next we got the already mentioned
warhammer titan which was possessed by
the tiber sister before aaron inherited
the power the warhammer
titan was especially hyped because it
was the last one
of the nine powers to be introduced to
us and it was definitely worth the wait
the warhammer titans design is
reminiscent of a medieval knight's armor
which gives it a very cool look beyond
that it can use its hardening powers
to form different kinds of weapons like
a sword a trident or the signature war
hammer beyond that the titan can form
spikes from the ground
or from its body the spike can be small
enough to just slow an enemy tightened
down
or large enough to lift them into the
air but to me the most impressive thing
about this titan is that it can form
more complicated and flexible weapons
like a crossbow
or a cattle nine tails whip that can
destroy buildings with one swing it's
clearly ridiculously strong but that
strength comes at a price
as mageth explains although the power of
the warhammer is immense
it is quickly exhausted and so one
strategy for defeating it
is to make it use its special hardening
abilities as much as possible
the other power that makes it near
undefeatable is its ability to be
operated remotely as we saw with the
tiber's sister
she didn't actually have to be in the
nape of her titan
she operated it while the real body was
safely encased in a titan crystal
underground
the titan body is connected to a cable
that is connected to the user's titan
crystal this pretty much means that if
you can't break through the crystal
you can't win and the only known way to
break through such a crystal is by using
the jaws or
claws of the jaw titan so it is very
lucky for aaron that porco's jaw titan
was present during that fight
so that aaron could inevitably use him
as a nutcracker to gain the warhammer
titan power for himself
currently in the manga aaron and amir
fritz are
summoning pastime shifters in the same
way that the tiber sister summoned her
own warhammer titan but they're just
doing so on a much much bigger scale
next up we have the beast titan which is
currently 17 meters tall
for this one you have to talk about
specific users when talking about its
power
because we now know it's not always an
ape-like titan
it can take on the appearance of many
different animals including an alligator
a deer
or even a flying creature it just so
happens that zeke's version
the one that we are most familiar with
takes the form of an ape we do know that
tom xaver
was the holder of the beast titan before
zeke he was a researcher and father
figure to zeke
they would often play catch which is
fitting when you consider
zeke's titan and its impressive throwing
abilities we never saw tom's beast titan
so we don't know for sure what animal
powers he had but we do know
that his beast titan wasn't too useful
in war so when it came time for the
royal blooded zeke to inherit the beast
titan from tom
marley must have felt like they really
hit the jackpot unlike tom's titan
zeke's beast titan was very very useful
in battle the marlene military states
that zeke's titan's pitching assault is
an unprecedented
awe-inspiring weapon zeke's titan can
crush rocks in his hands
and throw them with deadly accuracy
these rocks can destroy buildings ships
and easily wipe out a charging army we
know he effortlessly beat reiner's
armored titan
when the latter tried to challenge him
on paradise island which is crazy to
think about considering tom's version
wasn't even useful in battle but even
more impressive is the ability that the
marlene military called a miracle
namely zeke's ability to turn people
into titans using his spinal fluid
and then to control them with a scream
he can turn these victims into titans
and this ability has been used by marlet
to fill enemy areas with countless
destructive titans for instance they
dropped many aldians over fort slava
and then zeke used his scream to turn
them into titans in midair
so when they hit the ground they would
cause devastating damage
the fact that zeke can then control
these titans albeit not perfectly
makes him all the more deadly and very
very useful in war
like many other titans zeke's titan can
use selective hardening and
unlike most titans z can talk in his
titan form in a data book zeke's beast
titan
also got an 11 out of 10 in intelligence
so his insane abilities are combined
with his
insane intellect and together they make
for a very formidable titan shifter
lastly we got the jaw titan and it's 4
known users that we'll get into i saved
one of the best and most interesting
titan powers for last as you'll see
the jaw titan is usually around 5 meters
tall it's small compared to the others
but it makes up for it with insanely
powerful jaws claws and
great speed and there may not be
anything sharper and more powerful
in the world of attack on titan than the
jaws and claws of the jaw titan as i
mentioned previously in this video
we don't know of anything else that
could break through the titan crystals
that annie and the tiber sister were
able to create around their bodies
except the jaws and claws of the jaw
titan this is why
aaron had to use porco's titan as a
titan nutcracker so he could absorb the
warhammer titan
the first known user of the jaw titan
was marcel galliard the older brother of
porco galliard
marcel's draw titan was very similar to
porcos as
both had visible hardening on their face
and significantly hardened claws
marley entrusted the jaw titan which
they called an assault unit to marcel
because he was quick-witted marlei
further called it the swiftest titan and
said its powerful claws and jaws could
crush just about anything
and i said this in my porco's draw titan
explain video but what i'm curious about
is if the marleian military knows about
an exception about anything that its
jaws and claws can't crush
because i'd be super interested in
knowing that the fact that they use the
words just about anything rather than
anything
makes me think they know of something
but it could be me just reading too much
into it
marcel's jaw titan in particular was
seen effortlessly destroying cannons
with its claws and jaws
then there's emir of the survey core not
to be confused with amir fritz the
founder
emir is the second known user of the jaw
titan she inherited it from marcel
after the latter pushed reiner to safety
marcel sacrificed his life to save
reiner from emir's mindless titan and
that's the only reason why emir
didn't end up with the armored titan
power instead amir's draw titan
was also known as the dancing titan it
had an easy time climbing walls and
trees
its chimpanzee-like body made it easier
for her to out-maneuver anyone in a
forest
but the small body meant that she was
easily overpowered when outnumbered by
attacking titans
in an open area notably emir's titan was
able to speak although not as well as
zekes and peaks
and unlike marcel's and porco's versions
it didn't have the noticeably hardened
face
and claws emir eventually willingly
allowed reiner to take her to marley
where porco galliard ended up inheriting
her titan power
as i explained in my porco's jaw titan
video aaron mikasa noticed that porco's
version was significantly faster than
amir's version of the jaw titan it fared
very well against aaron's attack titan
in marley
but since aaron had help from levi and
then mikasa porco didn't have a chance
of winning the battle
he did however effortlessly bite through
aaron's hardened fists
and even break through the tiber sisters
titan crystal a detail that never
ceases to impress me eventually on
paradise island a very injured porco
gave himself over to be eaten by falco
grice after the latter was turned into a
mindless titan by
zeke's scream falco's version of the
jotan is probably the most
hyped-up titan of all in the manga right
now from the beginning
there was foreshadowing that falco would
become a flying titan when he was
introduced he was reaching out for a
bird
and his name itself is a reference to a
bird however
when the ninth titan turned out to be
the warhammer titan people stopped
talking about the idea of a flying titan
as much
however somehow we ended up getting the
flying titan we all wanted
although it took longer than we thought
it would and didn't actually happen in
quite the same way
in the latest chapter we finally saw our
first fully realized flying titan and it
was falco
he had a beak huge wings and was big
enough to carry quite a few people on
his back as he moved speedily through
the air
we can assume that he still has powerful
jaws and claws
and that he's super fast as is
characteristic of the jaw titan but his
is also very unique from any other jaw
time version we've seen before like a
beast
titan he's gained animal powers namely
that of a bird
why would a draw titan gain animal
powers you might ask well it's because
falco was
turned into a titan using zeke's spinal
fluid
and so as gabby explained he's showing
characteristics of the beast titan
like the female titan he can manifest
the abilities of another titan
and this is not that far fetched since
certain titan powers like hardening and
the titan screaming abilities have
appeared in different titan shifters
in different ways titan powers
definitely seem to be more fluid than we
at first thought
and that's every single one of the 20
titan shifters and you can see now
why it makes sense to discuss all of
them because there can be such a big
difference between different users
of the same titan power as i previously
mentioned in this video
emir did summon countless more past
titan shifters on aaron's skeletal titan
back
we don't know enough about these to
discuss them in detail here but it was
fun seeing so many interesting titan
designs
including what looked like an alligator
titan a reindeer titan
a fantastic four thing titan a long neck
to dinosaur titan
and many more if you would like to see
more of these interesting titan shifter
designs
i strongly recommend you go through
chapter 135 of the manga and take your
time to examine them in further detail
but as far as this video goes that is it
thank you so much for watching and
staying tuned until the end
i'm sure this will end up being a very
long video if you did enjoy it i would
really appreciate it if you wore a
hammer smash that like button
really destroy it because these kinds of
videos take a lot of time and if you
smash that like button that will let me
know
that you guys want to keep seeing these
kinds of attack on titan videos
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all
or you will miss future attack on titan
videos if you haven't yet
make this the day you subscribe and
while you wait for the next video
to drop feel free to check out my
growing attack on titan playlist where
we got videos about the ackermans and
all their powers the titans ranked from
weakest to strongest
and much much more link to that is in
the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect liam
thompson pattay hefarithian phoenix
anime 987
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tennelle
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kazowski cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games manwa freaks
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
by clicking the blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support as you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
so
you